[Music]
thank you
you've made tonight
[Music]
welcome back to the Overlook Hotel I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down the ending of The Shining
after our initial breakdown in the film
hit 1 million views I thought I'd return
to one of my favorite films to discuss
the final shot in detail throughout this
video we'll be going over what it really
means all the theories behind it and
hopefully finally giving some closure to
one of Cinema's most haunting shots if
you enjoy the video please hit the
thumbs up button and also don't forget
to subscribe for breakdowns like this
every day by the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
shiny
[Music]
now this is something that's had people
scratching their heads for the best
product for decades in case you don't
know the book takes place in the year
1975 with a 1980 film taking place
roughly around the same time it follows
the Torrance family as they move into
the Overlook Hotel to act as caretakers
over the winter Jack ends up going
seemingly insane and after he tries to
kill a family they managed to escape
leaving him lost in the hotel's vast
hedge maze overnight he succumbs to the
elements but we close out with a big
mystery in the hotel hanging up is a
photo with Jack seemingly in attendance
at the July 4th ball in 1921. this
roughly puts the event as something had
happened almost 60 years prior seemingly
cementing that Jack's always been the
caretaker there you've always been the
caretaker when discussing the ending
Kubrick preferred to keep things
ambiguous but he did give a little
insight to what might be going on the
director stated the ballroom photograph
at the end suggests The Reincarnation of
Jack as we know throughout the film we
get lots of lip service given the idea
that Jack's always been part of the
hotel and it's possible his final shot
shows him from a past life working there
as the caretaker this is Meredith and
Albert Grady as well who we meet at one
point in the film The Great is a Delbert
Grady now then she would discover that
he in fact killed his children because
they were attempting to destroy the
hotel he did this with an ax and the
twins at haunt Danny are of course meant
to make us instantly think it's them the
story about the murder is told early on
when Jack goes for the job and that
should kind of explain everything right
well on rewatches you might notice that
not everything lines up and in fact
there are some inconsistencies when the
manager is telling Jack this story he
refers to Grady by a slightly different
name and also gets something incorrect
with the twins my predecessor and his
job hired a man named Charles Grady is
the winter caretaker he came up here
with his wife two little girls who think
about eight and ten
killed his family with an ax
although he says they're different ages
when we see them they are clearly twins
cubic hired twins to play the role and I
think it's a mistakeable that these are
the same age but why would kibra get
such an important detail wrong and why
did nobody catch the differences in the
names when they were writing the scripts
well I believe that's because it's
intentional and it further backs up this
idea of reincarnation there are likely
two different gradies at the hotel at
some point or another with them
potentially both being called there
through fate or a higher power that's
what it feels the case with Jack as well
and potentially the two spirits of them
are trapped in a cycle involving it if
we're sticking with this idea I think
the life of one of the quote-unquote
caretakers is that they're born they
live to a certain age one they hear of a
job at the Overlook and apply for it and
upon getting it they end up murdering
their family and are then born again and
repeat the cycle I believe that the
hotel retains some of their Essence
similar the ghosts we see floating
around but I'll talk about this
absorption Theory later on in the video
now if this is the case then not fully
formed almost like burnt toast whilst
the newborn version of them's out there
in the world upon them returning to the
hotel they somewhat feel whole again and
slowly the visions of their past life
come back this is why Jack Witnesses a
party not too dissimilar to the one he
attended as that's an element of his
past life that's coming back to him now
due to them being a certain age by the
time they get to the job the hotel would
likely need another to feed on it in the
interim this is where the other comes in
and the cycle continues rather than
having 34 years in between the
characters being born and then getting
to a point where they're old enough to
take the job they have another running
alongside them who's probably in their
early 20s when the others being born
hope that makes sense as it's a little
difficult to understand but both
characters are clearly operating at
different times and carrying the murders
out at different times too the idea of
cyclical violence is something that the
hotel is very much built upon so it
makes sense it would operate in this
manner too it was built on a Native
American burial ground and this would
have likely been conquered through
Bloodshed Charles and Albert Grady both
killed their families with an ax and
Jack was attempting to try and replicate
it and the buck talks about olive oil
and acts that have happened there and at
one point Jack even finds a scrapbook
detailing everything involved in the
hotel's entire history in the burger
goes on for chapters and chapters and
they phrase it in a way that he's
researching it to write his own book on
the hotel however what it tells the
reader is that this is a violent place
where lots of evil things have gone down
at we see the ghosts throughout the film
and lots of them appear in the Final Act
especially this shows that these
apparitions become almost trapped in the
hotel for eternity with Jack likely
suffering the same fate which this photo
demonstrates now when going back through
the film it's clear that Jack has The
Shining and this is made even more
apparent by the movie Dr sleep like his
dad Dany shares his alcoholism which we
learned is actually used as a way to do
his Visions this is why I think Jack
drank as well and it also explains how
his a able to see the ghosts now this
time around the hotel wants to take not
only him but also Dany as well because
judo's shining abilities this will make
him even more powerful this kind of
bells off the back of the absorption
thing that we talked about before and
constantly taking the essence of people
could help it grow and stay alive
although like to sleep hadn't been
dreamed up at this point we did see
something similar happening in that in
the film we meet the true not who feed
off the steam given to them by powerful
psychics they retain some of this in a
steam jar and breathe it in in order to
keep themselves young that could be the
case here too with a hotel constantly
draining the live from Jack and its
guests May constantly call them back and
then Feast off the new life that they've
been given it's also important to bear
in mind that Jack appears as the
bartender in doctor sleep so Matt could
again cement this Theory again I know
it's kind of retroactively changing the
ending but it's clear that at least Mike
Flanagan thought the hotel absorbed him
too and there are theories at those in
the photos could be the victims that the
hotel has taken and rather than this
being a photo of 1921 Jack's just been
absorbed into the images here and it's
now showing his face to the world this
would explain why the family never
walked past the photo and noticed it
though to be fair they might just have
not been paying attention to it it is
kind of terrifying to think though that
Jack Souls trapped behind that photo
screaming for eternity whilst outwardly
his face is Forever Frozen in this
unwavering grin now if the absorption
theory is incorrect then The
Reincarnation thing could mean that this
version of Jack was just snapped at the
party and then years later he showed up
back there in his new life either way
what this represents is that the hotel
has had and will continue to have
violent events attached to it it doesn't
matter how long it takes it will
eventually happen and the same sorts of
people and mindsets will be pulled in by
its Allure whether it's the isolation or
the rage bubbling over the top of them
people the hotel will learn those who
can manipulate and eventually they'll
fall victim to it Jack's a broken mind
due to his alcoholism and he's been
fired from his job teaching due to a
violent Outburst that happened against
the student we also know that he's hit
Danny as well and he's clearly someone
the hotel has and will sink its teeth
into in order to get What It Wants It
chooses victims like this because they
have their weaknesses but also filing
our specs of their personalities that
make them the perfect bit to be someone
to carry out its misdeeds it's kinda
scary to think about but I think that's
what makes the movie so Everlasting now
the original photo itself actually has
an innocent story behind it and it was
just taken at a ball during a party in
1923. this was originally shown in a
book discussing how superimposition was
carried out and it discussed the
techniques used to replace heads before
computers existed anyway it's crazy how
well Photoshop existed but it's crazy to
think how this Final Shots remain in the
mind of viewers over the last 43 years
this is a film that arguably has one of
the most haunting funnel frames of a
film ever and I really hope you've
enjoyed us going back through it to
discuss what it could actually mean and
of course love to hear your thoughts on
the film as well so make sure you
comment below and let me know please
drop a like on the video and if you want
to support the channel as a member of
the spoiler Society then please click
the join button you'll get early access
to videos like this every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
we also have a midge store over at
shopzeroedition.com which sells lots of
nodian spy t-shirts at some more just
launched the secret Invasion slash Pulp
Fiction spy t-shirt so if you want to
head over there and help us out then the
Link's in the description if you want
something else to watch then check out
our full breakdown of The Shining which
will be linked on screen right now
because you every single aspect of the
movie talk about the making of the the
history behind it and all the hidden
symbolism and details that you might
have missed by the way huge thank you
for saying to the video I've been poor
I'll see you next time take care peace